he appeared by video link which is a bit  unusual for a first appearance he  appeared to be in Gray's police station  where we think he's been held since his  arrest last Wednesday morning he  confirmed his name address his date of  birth he's 25 years old asked his  nationality he said he was British he  was sitting in a room appeared to be on  his own he faces more than 40 charges 39  of them are manslaughter of those  migrants who were found dead in the  trailer which his cab was used to pick  up that trailer  he faces conspiracy to traffic people  conspiracy to assist illegal immigration  and money laundering charges he wasn't  asked to plead he was remanded in  custody he didn't ask for bail and he if  he fights these charges the court was  told he would stand trial at the Old  Bailey early next year he will appear  there on the 25th of November a number  of suspects still wanted the prosecutor  said